hi my name is Wes McKinney and I'm here
to give you a quick overview of some of
the things you can do with the pianist
library for Python I just wrote this
book published in last October Python
for data analysis so if you're
interested in these kinds of tools I
suggest that you pick it up it's very
accessible and nice introduction to get
up and running with with Python and
pandas so one of the things that people
use pandas for is for loading data into
Python especially larger data stored and
CSV files or many different file formats
so here I have a CSV file containing
about a half million rows some minute
bar data for a bunch of stocks and I'm
just going to load in the apple the
Apple data so time series operations is
one big reason why people use pandas so
in this data there's a column that
contains the time stamps of strings is
about five years of data and I can
remove that date column from the data
frame convert it to Candice's timestamp
format and set it as the index of the
data frames so now so now the data frame
represents a collection of time series
I've got a little helper function here
to load some more data later so there
are a number of different indexing
conveniences that pandas gives you so
one is to be able to select all the data
points at a particular time across many
days so here if we wanted all of the 10
a.m. data which is you know 15 1500 GMT
I could say you know Apple bars at time
time 15 time is a Python Python object
I'm just looking at the first 10 rows so
we get all the ten o'clock data I can
also look and say you know the price all
of the closing prices on October 15th
2009 by passing a string for the for the
date and it selects out that subset of
the time series pandas makes it really
easy to to resample time series so if I
wanted to say take the close price
column resample its monthly and compute
the mean median and standard deviation I
can specify that really concisely and
get back a data frame that contains
three columns for each of the three
things that I aggregated it also has
moving window functions so if I wanted
to say compute a 10 day moving standard
deviation
compute business daily samples of that
and plot it I can do that in just a
couple of commands another area that is
is very important in the design of the
libraries and data alignment so suppose
that I have two time series which have a
different set of dates I can still add
these together and it automatically
aligns things behind the scenes if I
create a data frame from two unaligned
time series it aligns them and puts the
it conforms the union of the the indexes
and creates a create some nice regularly
indexed rectangular table you can also
do that with combining together two data
frames to hear.i a subsample the Apple
bar data and the IBM bar data I take a
90% sub sample and then I concatenate
them think of them together and create a
new data frame which contains all of the
bar data for both of the stocks and they
this result has a hierarchical index and
I'll talk a bit more about that a little
bit another area that is very important
is in missing data handling because
missing data is a fact of life in many
cases so here's that little data frame
from earlier I call the count method it
returns the number of non missing values
in each column but with arithmetic
methods such as statistical methods like
sum and mean here I computed the sum of
the columns and an excluded the missing
values automatically here I competed the
mean of the rows and it excluded the na
s that are found in the B column you
could also drop the n/a so here I said
drop in a how equals all and that only
drops rows if they're all in a but if I
just do regular vanilla drop in a it
drops any row that contains in an A I
can also fill in A's with a Miss it with
this fixed value or if I have you know
time series or some other form of
ordered data I can do interpolation type
methods like fill forward here's an
example where I take this daily data
resample it to for hourly frequency I
can you know which computes which gives
you missing data with no extra arguments
but I can convert to for hourly and then
use the F fill method with limit 3 to
fill forward three periods of data for
each day and this is also excellent for
doing Tom's SQL type
group-by operations gives you a very
flexible way to do group operations on
data see I've got some essentially
randomly generated data that represents
a set of hypothetical stock portfolios
so I've got a data frame of some
portfolios along with an Associated
Industry Classification for the stocks
and also a currency currency
classification so something that I might
want to do is to group by industry and
compute compute means for each of the
columns and the data frames to do that I
say DF group by industries that mean and
that gives me a new data frame
containing industry means now it can
then be say plotted to create a nice a
nice summary of what went on what's
going on in those groups and the data I
can augment that grouping with two group
variables here industries and currencies
and that gives me back a data frame or
that which is now indexed by industry
and currency and you have group means
for each of those pairs there you can
also apply transformations to the group
so here I group by industries and
currency I have a little z-score
function which subtracts the mean
divided by the standard deviation and
now I use the apply method that gives me
a normalized result which I can then
group by the keys again and aggregate
with mean and standard deviation and
verify that within each group the mean
is approximately zero and the standard
deviation is one so this whole
hierarchical indexing business is a key
feature in Panda so you might see this
and say well okay what's going on here
so the index is a point is a data
structure which can be which can be
modified but it's you know it's a fixed
quantity on the data frame so here if I
select the momentum column from the data
frame I get back now a series or one
dimensional pan this object which is
indexed by the same industry currency
hierarchical index I can also select
just the tech chunk of the data from the
rows using the IX indexing field and I
can just select out that little slice
from the data there are core methods for
working with hierarchically indexed data
stack and unstack so stack rotates data
from the columns into the row so here by
stacking this this data frame I create a
one dimensional object which now
three levels of the next thing that can
be then unstacked so I can say unstack
the industry field and now I get back a
new data frame which has industries
along the columns and then currency and
factor name in the index pan this is
also very good for doing merge and join
type operations as you might do in an
SQL database so here are some movie data
from the movie lens movie lens project
and so I've got a yeah it's you know
quite a bit of data and plus it's taking
a lot longer to load because I'm
recording a screencast so you're I have
these three data frames which are linked
together here we have movie date movie
metadata movie ratings and user metadata
and these can all be joined together in
a very straightforward way I use the
pandas merge function to join the
ratings and users and further merge that
merge result with the movie data to
create a single single data frame
containing all of the relevant data that
we want to aggregate so we could then
take that group by title compute the
number of observations for each title
and then select out movies that received
at least a thousand ratings in the data
set for further analysis so we call that
free titles and that gives us back
basically a big data structure of a list
of list of movie titles and then we
could do something like group by title
take the rating column compute group
means of that select just the frequently
voted on titles ordered by value and
select the last twenty value so these
are the highest rated movies in the data
set that received at least a thousand
ratings so we can then take those those
titles filter down the data set take
data data title the movie titles filter
just to the set of highest rated titles
you notice that dr. strangelove has a
very long title so I'm gonna truncate
that to 25 characters and now I'm gonna
take that filtered master data set group
by title and gender compute mean ratings
and then unstack the gender field so now
I get a nice data frame illustrating how
men and women voted on these highly
rated highly rated titles and of course
we could change this from meme to count
we can see actually how many ratings are
in each of these groups pandas may
actually makes this kind of you know
pivot table type operation even easier
to do by using the table method I can
just say oh I want to pivot do Coromant
pivot table on the ratings data group by
title and gender aggregate with me and
then I get a nice sort of nicely indexed
arranged pivot table out of the results
so doing things with group buys a little
bit more by hand there's a large set of
summary statistics and other ways that
you can slice and dice and analyze
tabular data so if we use the value
counts method on the title column that
just gives us back Panda series showing
the number of movie ratings for each of
the titles sorted in descending order so
you can see that you know the Star Wars
movies received a ton of ton of votes
along with American Beauty and that goes
all the way down to the movies that only
received a 1:1 rating there's also
methods like described which gives you a
summary a bunch of summary statistics
for the data and that can of course be
combined with the group by facility to
get a bunch of statistics across
different subsets of the data set so
this is just a quick overview of some
things that you can do with pandas I
hope you find it interesting and use the
library thank you